-Hello, everyone,
and welcome to "Late Night"
from my hallway.
As I'm sure you all know,
our show is dark,
our staff is all at home,
and we have no idea
when we're going to be back,
but obviously
it's not just a surreal time
for us,
it's a surreal time
for everyone.
We're all trying to process it,
so we thought we'd start
doing that
the way we always do,
with "A Closer Look."
Now, you might notice that
I'm doing this "Closer Look"
from inside my house,
and it may be weird
to do it from a hallway,
but at least I'm not doing it
from a public beach!
Look at those dummies.
Let me be clear.
I'm not saying people are dumb
for going to the beach
during a pandemic,
which they are.
I'm saying you're for going
to the beach, period.
You could die from going
to a beach right now,
and it's still not in
the top five worst things
that can happen to you
at a beach.
When I die, I fully expect
my last words to be,
"At least I don't have
to go to the beach anymore."
I mean, I'm not happy
being stuck inside all the time,
but at least I'm not finding
sand in my butt crack -- yet.
Anyway, "Late Night's"
in quarantine
but we're still processing
a public health crisis,
economic crisis, crisis of
leadership at the federal level.
There's a lot to process,
so for more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
The stock market plummeted
again this morning,
and the number of coronavirus
cases across the world
has now surpassed 300,000,
with about 40,000
here in the U.S.
Or as the president assured us
at the start of this crisis...
-When you have 15 people,
and the 15 within
a couple of days
is going to be down to
close to zero...
-Ah! So close.
Trump's like the dumbest "Price
is Right" contestant in history.
"Donald, how much for this
brand-new Porsche,
dining set,
and 10-day luxury stay
at the Ritz-Carlton in Hawaii?
-Close to zero.
[ "Price is Right"
horn plays ]
-"Does the horn sound
mean I won?
Was that the winner's horn?"
I really hope people remember
that comment
as we watch a pandemic overwhelm
our health care system
and wreck our economy
while we sit on our couches
scrolling all the way
to the bottom of Netflix
looking for something new
to watch?
"Honey, look, look, honey.
Honey, I found a documentary
called, let me see,
'Secret Wildcats
of the Scottish Highlands.'
I don't think we've seen
that one yet, honey.
No, we watched it last night
and the secret is,
it's a boring documentary."
Because while the federal
government could have been
ramping up testing, tracing,
and quarantining cases
and containing the spread,
the president was lying
and claiming this was all
no big deal.
In fact, we now know,
thanks to new reporting
in the "Washington Post,"
that U.S. intelligence agencies
were issuing ominous
classified warnings
in January and February
about the global danger
posed by the coronavirus,
while President Trump
and lawmakers played down
the threat
and failed to take action.
So either he knew about it
the whole time and lied,
or he wasn't paying attention
during his briefings,
and honestly, both are
probably true.
Donald Trump cannot stand
when someone else
is talking in a meeting.
I mean, look at him.
He literally looks down
at the table
and hugs himself like he's
hoping it's all a dream.
Pretty soon he's just going
to start going to meetings
wearing a, I don't know,
a ThunderShirt?
But of course, we can't expect
Trump to actually
read one of his intelligence
briefings
unless Sean Hannity
holds it up to the screen
during his show.
In fact, the "Post" reported
that Trump's advisers
struggled to get him
to take the virus seriously.
Health Secretary Alex Azar
couldn't get through to Trump
to speak with him about
the virus until January 18th,
when he reached Trump by phone.
The president interjected
to ask about vaping
and when flavored vaping
products would be
back on the market.
He was more concerned
about vaping than coronavirus.
He is a 16-year-old
high school burnout
trapped in a 70-year-old
retiree's body.
Our hospitals might run out
of masks and ventilators,
but at least Trump will
still make sure
they have plenty of
Peppermint E-Juice.
"Smoke this.
It'll make the pain stop.
Or it won't. There's no science
behind any of this."
And now, partially because
of Trump's negligence,
over 100 million Americans,
nearly a third of the country,
are under stay-home orders.
Basically it's like a cross
between a staycation
and a "Saw" movie.
Now the situation
is grim and surreal,
but that doesn't mean
there haven't been
moments of positivity,
like those penguins
who are let loose
in the aquarium
and allowed to gawk
at the other animals,
finally allowing them
to be as snooty
as the tuxedos nature
provided them.
"Look at the riffraff
in their casual wear.
This is an aquarium,
not an above-ground pool."
Or Steve Martin playing
his banjo in, I don't know,
I guess the middle of the woods.
And you know things are bad
when the sound of someone
playing a banjo in the woods
is comforting.
Usually that's when you run
back to the camper
and head for the city.
I will say, "Deliverance"
would have been a whole
entirely different movie
if it had been Steve Martin
instead of that weird kid.
"How was your camping trip?"
"You know what?
It was hilarious.
It was so funny.
It was so funny
even when someone
got shot through the head
with an arrow.
Now, countries across the world
have taken drastic measures
to slow the spread
of the pandemic by, quote,
"flattening the curve,"
which sounds like
something a CrossFit instructor
would yell during a workout.
"Come on, Janet!
Janet, let's finish those squats
and flatten those curves!"
But it basically just means
slowing the spread out
over a longer period time,
rather than having one big spike
that overwhelms the health care
system all at once.
European governments
from France to Italy to Spain
have all taken extreme measures
to lock down their countries
and slow the spread
of the disease,
and in Germany, even
Chancellor Angela Merkel
was apparently getting ready
when she was photographed
over the weekend
at her local supermarket
buying four bottles of wine
and some toilet paper.
Either she's preparing
to self-quarantine,
or she's about to get hammered
and TP the principal's house.
[ German accent ]
"Take that, Mr. Himmelschmitt!
Oh, I just the saw the light!
Go! Run! Schnell! Schnell!"
And drastic measures
are already having
a major impact on economic
activity across the world.
"The Financial Times"
reported on Sunday
that road traffic has always
fallen in most major cities.
Rome, Paris, and New York
have all seen rush-hour traffic
running at considerably below
their usual average levels.
Rush-hour traffic has fallen
in New York.
And in New York, all traffic
is rush-hour traffic.
Every hour is rush hour.
If someone gets a flat tire
in Queens,
the whole Eastern Seaboard
locks up for three hours.
If you try and catch a cab
in Midtown at rush hour,
you'd be better off just
ordering all the parts
and building your own cab.
Order them from rockauto.com,
which is a commercials
a lot of writers
on our staff enjoy.
And yet, there are still
some people who don't seem
to be taking the situation
seriously,
particularly young people
who are still crowding
beaches and parks.
So over the weekend,
New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
had a message for them.
-We do have an issue
with younger people
who are not complying.
You want to have an opinion?
Have an opinion.
But you can't have
your own facts.
"Well, young people don't
get this disease."
You are wrong.
You can get this virus.
And you can transfer
the virus.
Social distancing works,
and you need social distancing
everywhere.
There's a significant
amounts of noncompliance,
especially in New York City,
especially in the parks.
I'm going to go down there
today.
I want to see what
the situation is myself.
-Yo, [bleep]
If you guys don't stay
at least 6 feet apart,
Andrew Cuomo will
turn this car around right now!
He's gonna go down to the parks
himself and bust some skulls,
and he's gonna bring
his brother Chris with him.
Look at these guys.
Not only are they
gonna enforce social distancing,
they're gonna
hang you upside down
and steal your lunch money.
Seriously, I would watch
an entire after-school special
with an undercover Andrew Cuomo
posing as a teen skateboarder,
you know, trying to bust kids
for hanging out in the park.
"Pot is cool.
You know what else is cool?
Staying inside
and reading books."
Also I love that one of
the slides in his presentation
literally said, "Young people,
you are wrong."
That is serious big dad energy.
"You were wrong. Now go
to your room for two months.
Think about what you did.
Better hear you
washing your hands in there."
So the coronavirus pandemic
has impacted
virtually every aspect
of society,
from Hollywood to sports
to politics.
Just yesterday we found out
that Rand Paul
was the first senator
diagnosed with coronavirus.
Thankfully his office says
that he's feeling fine,
and that's great news.
Now we could point out
the fact that Paul
was the only senator to vote
against the bipartisan
coronavirus aid package,
or the fact that he stood
by an incompetent president
who botched the response
to this crisis
and called criticism
of his response a hoax.
But I want to focus on this
part of the story.
-Out of an abundance of caution,
Senator Paul,
despite the fact
he did not have symptoms,
decided to get tested
about six or seven days ago
So what we're learning is that
in that time frame,
those six or seven days
since he got tested,
he has been up on Capitol Hill
attending GOP lunches.
He also,
as we reported earlier today,
was spotted at the Senate gym.
-Senator Rand Paul tests
positive for coronavirus,
and fellow lawmakers
spotted him
in the Senate swimming pool
earlier today.
-So Rand Paul thought
he might have coronavirus,
and he went to the gym
and the pool.
What else did he do, lick every
desk in the Senate chamber
and shake hands with
the Lincoln Memorial?
Also of course he goes
to the Senate pool.
That explains his hair.
Dude, wear a swimming cap.
Or maybe that is.
Is that a swimming cap?
Seriously, if you think you
have coronavirus,
you're supposed to stay home,
not go to the gym.
Coronavirus doesn't care
if you're jacked.
I mean, Idris Elba got it,
and look at him.
If anyone's capable
of knocking out coronavirus
by punching it,
it's Idris Elba.
And now several other
Republican senators
have been forced
to self-quarantine,
including Utah Senator
Mitt Romney.
Trump, who's feuded with Romney,
apparently found out
about that fact in real time
during his daily
coronavirus reality show
on Sunday night,
and deployed his trademark
charm and compassion.
-On top of Senator Paul,
now four senators
are in isolation,
and the rules say that they
were going to vote --
-Who are they, please?
Who are they?
-Mitt Romney, Senator Lee...
-Senator Gardner...
-Senator Gardner.
-...and Rick Scott
-Senator Rick Scott also.
Two of them were in contact --
-Well, I guess Rick
is coming out.
-With the critical stimulus
package vote expected --
-Romney's in isolation?
-Yes.
-Gee, that's too bad.
Go ahead.
-Do I detect sarcasm there, sir?
-No, no, none whatsoever.
-"No, no"?
Oh, that wasn't sarcasm?
So you're genuinely,
genuinely concerned
about Romney's well-being?
Did you also send him
a get-well card that said,
"Oh, you're so sick?
I'm so sorry."
That's just a reminder that
Donald Trump never passes up
an opportunity to remind us
that he is an awful person,
even in the midst
of a global pandemic.
It's almost like he's afraid
we'll forget.
Like, he's worried
that if he's too focused
on solving the crisis,
people won't remember
he's also the same ass [bleep]
who once tweeted,
"I have never seen a thin person
drinking Diet Coke."
In fact, last night after
yet another rambling,
self-absorbed performance,
Trump, who just recently
called himself
a "wartime president,"
took to Twitter to complain
about press coverage
of his disastrous
coronavirus response.
"I watch and listen
to the fake news CNN,
MSDNC, ABC, NBC, CBS,
some of Fox desperately,
foolishly pleading
to be politically correct,
'The New York Times'
and 'Washington Post,'
and all I see is hatred of me
at any cost.
Don't they understand that they
are destroying themselves?"
How do you have time
to watch six networks
and read two newspapers?
I've been home with two kids
for a week, and the only thing
I've read is the back of a box
of Clorox Wipes
and the only thing I've watched
is my wife roll her eyes at me
for not knowing how to
make oatmeal.
Trump thinks he's
a wartime president because
anytime someone asks him
a question, he's like,
"Okay, it's wartime."
If you want to be a wartime
president, you can't tweet
petty complaints
about the media.
Churchill never started
any of his speeches by saying,
"We shall fight them
on the beaches.
on the landing ground.
Even though the fake news
will never give me credit."
My voice coach has been
unavailable,
in case you're wondering why
that Churchill was so bad.
We're in this crisis in part --
He's not sick or anything,
he's just doing other stuff.
We're in this crisis in part
because of the authoritarian
cult of personality
that surrounds our president.
Instead of facing
the stark truth,
Trump demands constant
praise and flattery.
In fact, at one point
last week,
a reporter simply tried to ask
Trump about the very real,
urgent concerns faced by
health care professionals
on the front lines about
the lack of medical equipment
like masks and ventilators.
Things are so bad
TV medical dramas
have been donating their
medical supplies
to hospitals in need
during the coronavirus panic.
That's right, our government
is such a mess,
TV shows have had to pitch in
by giving every hospital
in the country masks,
ventilators,
and one super hot doctor who
gets killed off in season 11.
"Don't get too close
to the cute doctor.
They never last.
They never do."
So Trump was asked about
those concerns
at one of his press conferences,
and this was his response.
-I just want to read you
some of what some of
the doctors on the front lines
of this crisis are saying.
Doctor --
-You mean the ones that are
saying good things
or bad things?
-I assure you, no one
who is saying good things
is a medical professional.
You think in the middle of
a global pandemic
that's overwhelming
our health care system
and triggering
an economic collapse
a reporter's gonna raise
their hands and say,
"Mr. President,
I want to read you
some of the beautiful tributes
that are pouring in"?
Seriously, why are you
like this?
Why do you have
the emotional maturity
of a middle school student
passing a note in class
that says, "Do you like me?
Check yes or yes"?
Now, on top of botching
a public health crisis,
Trump and his Republican
allies in Congress
are also trying to ram through
a stimulus package
they negotiated
with themselves
as the economy craters
and millions of vulnerable
working Americans miss out
on their paychecks
and struggle to make it
through the crisis.
Trump and his allies want
to shovel bailout money
into the pockets of corporations
without any strings attached.
They've also proposed
a one-time $1,000 check
to Americans struggling
through the crisis.
During a live stream yesterday,
Senator Bernie Sanders,
who's called for monthly
payments of $2,000
said that wasn't nearly
enough.
-I know some of my Republican
colleagues are talking about,
gee, a one-time $1,000 payment.
Really? Really?
Yeah, that will last you
for two or three weeks,
and what happens after that?
-Okay, first of all,
"Really?" is my segment, Bernie.
You don't see me going around
blasting millionaires
and billionaires.
Okay, actually, yeah, no,
I have done that.
All right, we're even.
Second, he's right.
A one-time check for 1,000 bucks
is not even close
to what we need.
What's Trump gonna
propose next,
free vaping products?
"To help with the pandemic,
we'll be sending every American
a monthly supply of
cucumber flavored Juul pods.
Smoke 'em before your lungs
are filled with coronavirus."
Instead of bailing out
big corporations
with no strings attached,
maybe we can bail out
the American people instead
by just giving them money.
Besides, if you send a check
to the airlines,
there's a good chance
it'll just get mixed up
with someone else's check
and end up in the wrong airport.
Why do cruises need a bailout
before workers
or rural hospitals?
No one wants to see Goofy
walking around
the deck of a Disney cruise
holding two bags of cash
and smoking a Juul.
Mm.
All right, I kind of
want to see it.
At this point it's become clear
that to get through this crisis
we're gonna have to rely
on state and local governments,
our courageous
health care workers,
our public health experts,
and each other
because when it comes to Trump,
the chances
he'll provide real leadership
are...
-Close to zero.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
We will see you soon.
Stay safe. Wash your hands,
and remember --
the beach sucks.